draped in the colours of a country under
attack ren's home in cambridge is ready
to welcome a ukrainian refugee but it
wasn't a difficult decision to make
katrina also happens to be her best
friend i was three years old when there
was a beirut war
and i
we narrowly escaped death at that wall
my dad saw a rocket pass by our window
and if it had taken a slightly different
trajectory i i wouldn't be here
britons who know the name of a ukrainian
person they wish to host can now fill
out an application but even with
passport details and relevant
documentation as ren found out it's
still not without its challenges when
you plan to arrive in the uk enter the
date in this format well that would be
nice if uh if she knew bless her when
she could arrive details few would know
when fleeing war
like niara and her daughter eleonora who
fled her kiev they've been sleeping
rough but have found a family in
hampshire willing to take them in she
knows plenty though who are still stuck
in limbo right now it's very important
to match to find uh the people in
ukraine who really needs any help it's
strange for me to ask for that for help
but right now we really need that help
for prospective hosts without a personal
connection it's a more uncertain way
friends introduced fiona to her match
she hopes to welcome olga and her
children as soon as she can i feel now
very pleased that i have by various
roots found you know connection and and
we seem to have
linked up with someone who a family who
we could provide accommodation too so
it's been it's been a tricky you know it
hasn't been easy to find that
route
so far 4 000 visas have been granted to
ukrainians with a relative in the uk
that's in addition to those opening
their homes out of goodwill some say the
process is too bureaucratic is the uk
doing enough i think the uk can do so
much more one of the things that
wouldn't really enable that would be to
lower the barriers to be able to find
safety in the uk by getting rid of the
visa restrictions and making people
enabling people to be able to come
directly to the uk rather than having to
apply before coming um that would enable
people to be able to come here far
faster those fleeing have had their
homes ripped from them and rebuilding
their lives will rely on support
hundreds of thousands want to help and
their first challenge is to get them
here
ashley harinag sky news